we've got some new merch items to tell
you about the be good to yourself crew
neck and teal
it's frosty and we got the new hoodie in
Bittersweet plus we've got the root beer
T-shirts from the uh root beer cartoon
all that and more at Theo vonstore.com
oh baby
oh dang look at the baby it's so tiny
is so tiny
God I remember that song remember that
from church
oh look at the babies
[Music]
dude on one time I went over to this
I don't know if it was Japanese or
Chinese or
it was some knees
that's all I'm gonna say
it was some knees it was Asian it was
you know what I'm saying you could damn
you could throw a pot of rice in this
church and hit an Asian
they probably had unlimited Asians in
there
you know it looked like uh
it looked like a um
it looked like a kind of an asiany
asiany
Asian
Asian thing spot Place Asian
it was Asian in there and ah
and I remember the first time I'd ever
heard a batch of Asians like that sing a
um Church hymn
you know I think they were
I don't know if they were first
generation or not or I'm not sure what
generation they were they were
some of them had the
the beat you know the little
some Asian people though if they get
real old they get that catfish hair
coming out of them
and you could get you know you put a
damn worm in front of one of them no
damn you know
they'll jump right out there damn kimono
they'll jump right out there damn Church
pajamas you know what I'm saying they
don't
you put a spinner bait or something you
throw a chicken liver in front of a
you know you got them catfish Asians
baby they're lurch
the alerts they got that you know
they got that last bit of karate left in
and Manila you know
because it you know
a lot of humans as they get older they
you cross with an animal at a certain
point
a lot of humans cross with an animal and
for a lot of Asian
for a lot of Asian that's catfish
you see that guy you know
but yeah I'd never been to a church
before
I had seen
um Asians
multiplication doing uh singing church
hymns
and it was pretty cool man it just shows
you that
um
that everybody can sing you know and
that there's a that everybody no matter
what ethnicity or culture
that they all can sing uh songs of faith
and have you know and be excited and
stuff like that and be at church I
remember I can't I can't remember the
song now but it was like uh do you see
the baby
do you see the baby
and they had a big screen in there and
if they'd have a picture of a uh
you know the three wise man going to get
uh Jesus Christ out of the
sand castle so
anyway what I'm trying to tell you is
Happy Mother's Day
I want to say that out there to every
type of mother every
every mother
there's a lot of you there's a lot of
you listening right now
and you're a mother you got something
you know
there's no other that's how I mean
that's God's peephole baby
that's how God looks out into the world
through a mother
that I mean you are the you are the
liaison
between
you know you're the on ramp between the
Lord
and Earth
you got that on ramp
you got that thorough fire
you know you got you know
you got that yum tunnel on you
and that's how God but God that's how
God serves them that's how he serves the
world
you know you're a woman's body a woman's
however they say it out there in some of
these other continents the vain yeah
that's how the you know
that's how that that that that that
that's how the Lord sir you know
that's how he just
puts people on earth
that's God's last hand that's his last
that's his that's how he reaches out
into the world
through a woman through a mother
that's really fascinating
if I told you there was a portal right
say I come up to you
you're sitting somewhere you're having a
sandwich or something you're having a
little
cut a meat cut up uh
cheese
you know you're having a cut of meat cut
of cheese two breads
you know what it is a sandwich
say you're having that you're sitting on
a little river bank or something I come
up to you
I say buddy
um
I'm gonna tell you where there's a
portal
where you can go into another Realm
you'd be you'd be there in a heartbeat
well that's what that's what a mother
mother that's the only way
the only way
to get from the brain of the of God
of the of the powers that be
of Mother Nature and father time the
only portal
is through a dang
woman a mother
or this [__] as some people call her I
don't you know I don't say that
but anyway I just want to yeah I want to
wish everybody a Happy Mother's Day you
know um
you know sometimes I think that uh
uh people are just ideas they're like
like what if God had an idea right and I
say God in the ethereum in the you can
whatever God you want
it can be everybody I have my you you
can have your own God
um
but I think of people sometimes as like
an idea of God like say you have an idea
write an idea kind of comes in it comes
into like it comes out of kind of
nowhere right
like if you have an idea in your head
it comes out of nowhere
and some some ideas there they do they
they stick around they
they turn into something
you know some ideas they make a
difference they some ideas really get
turned into something and can adjust the
world can
um
can change things can adjust a fan can
adjust something small or as big as the
whole world you know ideas they can
you don't know how big an idea can be or
how far an idea can go right
if we have an idea
so sometimes I think that humans they're
just ideas
of God really you know
it's like we show up into existence
we have a purpose sometimes sometimes we
don't
sometimes we evaporate and disappear
early you know
sometimes we stay around for a long time
sometimes we change our environment
uh and sometimes we we we can change the
world you know
so I don't know if this is making sense
but
I feel like life it's like being a lot
it's like we're almost like an idea of
God
like if we have an idea it comes into
fruition we do things with it some of
them are really helpful some of them
kind of come and go
but if God when God has an idea that's
us that's a person we're his idea we're
like ideas of God we come into life we
meander
some sometimes we have an effect on
things sometimes we don't
and uh
and there we go
so
not sure if that makes sense but um
that's something that's just been going
on in my head uh I'm grateful to be here
with you today
um I'm grateful to be thinking about
mothers
I'm grateful to be thinking about
I got to see my own mother last weekend
in Phoenix Arizona
she came out there and
and we had a nice time
you know it's been a long journey with
my own mother uh getting to know her and
uh since we didn't have a connection
when I was young getting to have a
connection as adults
um
you know I talk a lot about that I'm not
going to go into that right now but it
was awesome to get to see her
um
we got to do the largest show we'd ever
done at the Arizona uh Financial Center
dang bro
dang
dude
warm up the Asians baby because I'll
sing about that oh the baby he's here
oh look at him
um that was magical I want to thank
everybody for coming out to that it's a
different type of energy man you're out
there on the stage and you feel a little
God I feel so little out there
in a club I feel normal size regular
size six foot 182.
one arm a little bit shorter than the
other
neither arm
that long
is neither law a medium arms it's
nothing you'd notice but if you know you
know
um
what was I talking about dang
oh in that big in that in that vast of a
space I feel like I think I almost feel
like a bird could come down and just
pick me up off the stage
you know it's almost like you feel like
the mouse you know somebody sees a mouth
they shine a light on it
and that's what it's like in there
because it's big it's dark there's a
light on you
and I'm like man a Big Bird's gonna come
and damn get me
God I don't want that
um
I don't want some big dirty bird picking
me up but uh
but that was incredible just thank you
guys for just being a part of my life
for uh wanting to come and see me one
and two uh wanting to let me see you
um
you know or it's just I'm just glad we
all get to spend our time together and
it's just been really it's been cool and
I know a lot of people they want to get
to interact more
um
you know and we do what we can
um but I just want to thank everybody
for coming out we did one show that was
in a circle and that's damn confu I mean
it's like damn bro
the whole time I feel like I'm
performing and asking people for
directions you know and nobody knows
where I mean it just it was in the round
at the celebrity theater and this place
looked like a uh
it looked like a White Castle
but like the like the the White Castle
like where
you know where
white lived or whatever you know it
looked like the last White Castle but
like the biggest greatest White Castle
it looked like a CEO or the CEO of White
Castle would live this place it's in a
just a big parking lot and there's just
a damn Castle in it but it's just a low
cast it was just like a short Castle
it's a low Castle just damn short
castling
so if you got it that you know this
Castle it's like a
you know short Castle
you're like damn what is this
but thank you I I had never done a thing
in the circle like that so it's damn I'm
damn dizzy
you know halfway through the jokes I
gotta hold on the stool or something
uh
it reminded me of the Gravitron you know
when you go to the fair as a child
you know where I lived you'd go to the
fair and uh
and
you get on the Gravitron and we go over
there a day early for 50 cents they let
you get on a ride
and you were experimental you didn't
realize it
you were a damn lab rat they were
testing to make sure this [__] worked
and
make sure there was no lice on the
equipment or whatever
because that God damn boy you get on one
wrong ride you itch for a month cuz
I mean I swear to God
my I have one but he had two nipples he
itched one of them [__] right off bro
that's how bad he got uh
body lice
he's down in one damn nipple coz
because the lice they need a place to
meet up at on the body
you know they're just like they're just
like a group of white people at a um
Music Festival
they every now and then they gotta meet
up somewhere and check on everybody
where's Rhonda
how's Ricky oh damn where's Donna
oh well Tammy and them left they left
they're gone
so uh
the lies are like that they want a place
to meet up and God forbid it because
it's your Weiner or uh
or something like that
or enter weiner that cooter
that end that eyed dog baby that end
weiner yeah you know what oh yeah y'all
got the hand winner don't ya hey let it
let me see that in when uh
I can't remember that Asian Church yeah
but thank God they met up on his nipple
dog and ate that [__] because you get
them body lice but um
anyway what I'm trying to tell you guys
is
oh yeah it was like the damn Gravitron
like the shape of the place and the
Gravitron you'd get over there a day
early to the uh to the parish Fair the
county fair
and you pay 50 cents
and let you get on the ride and the
Gravitron you laid back against the wall
and the whole thing would spin
the damn thing was spinning
and it used all the power in the
community damn your mom's blender would
damn shut down seven blocks away
so this [__] could Spain
and it was you could hear your you know
the dad your dad works at the factory
that [__] shut down
everybody's having power outages and
right there in the middle of the
fairgrounds the Gravitron is spinning
there and then you can't even it you get
pushed against the side it's so much
inside you can't close your mouth or
eyes you're just like yeah I'm having
fun
and then the guy right running it he'd
be in the middle he was always this rock
and roll dude and he'd be like do you
wanna ride
and one person you could barely the the
centrifugal force was so strong you
could barely get your arm up a little
bit like
and then he damned that guy would show
you his damn weiner every time
that guy was a damn
he was just a visual pedophile that guy
he'd show you that sprout
that body Branch homie you know what I'm
talking about
that nut snake baby that wiener
who damnedest and you couldn't you
couldn't close your eyes or anything
everybody's mouth and eyes were just
wide open because you were spinning on
the Gravitron
and he just he you know he didn't do
anything but he'd show you that [__]
I don't know what we're talking about
happy Mother's Day
that's what we're trying to say here
and we're grateful
to a lot of beautiful mothers out there
we we love you moms and um
and thank you for giving us this life
whatever our life is
now the tough part is when you're not
enjoying your life you know uh
uh to then still find that gratitude to
your mother
but you know there's no
there's I don't know when it happened in
time that we started to think that life
while it is extremely unique
right it's extremely unique it's so rare
you know Neil deGrasse was on here
and he was talking about the Rarity that
you exist
the odds that you exist
I mean you may not you may you may hate
math
but you are math you were a equate you
are a
carry the one to carry the one million
the odds
that we that you that are that any one
of us exists
they're astronomical
or astronomical
but somewhere along the lines we you
know we started to think I guess that
life was supposed to be a comfort a
comfortable thing
and I don't know when that happened I
think that happened for me too
you know and maybe some of that is just
an American societal uh
idea
since we live in a and and and have
lived
historically and one of the more
comfortable countries
you know where we've had a lot of
um blessings and Gifts you know we've
had a lot of
we've had a lot of cash and prizes we've
you know we have water we have roofs we
have uh food you know we have our needs
met
um
that we started to just think that life
uh was is supposed to be
a comfortable Journey
but if you look out through time man it
is not it's never really been that
people have battled plagues
lightning
um
what else
AIDS
um
flash flooding
and
dangerous animals baby all of that
anyway I get in my head sometimes that
it's this com it's got It's it's
supposed to be this comfortable thing as
opposed to that it's supposed to be this
journey it's supposed to be this
experience
uh that doesn't really have any
guarantees you know
um
and I wish I could look at life more
that way because I think I wouldn't uh I
might have I might I wouldn't be
I'd probably find less disappointment in
things if I looked at life more as like
okay here I am
on this journey
as opposed to
why isn't my life going a certain way
it'd be more like
life
it was never promised to go a certain
way
it's just life
you know it's just like an idea it comes
along
it could
anything can happen to it
so I'm a little all over the place
uh but
[Music]
I'll sit and tell you a story
thank you
I've been moving way too fast
[Music]
um yeah good to be here
uh thank you for being a part of my life
thank you for uh blessing me with your
time today and we are out here and we
are alive
and this is life
this is what it is
you know if I can accept life on what it
is where it's at
then uh I'm in a match I'm in a much
better space usually
you know if I have to if I show up with
too many expectations
then I'm on a man
I'm always going to be
uh disappointed
you know I'm always going to be
disappointed
but if I can get my if I can get myself
to be like okay let's see what's gonna
happen today let's see how it goes
oh it's going good oh it's going bad
it's not really going good or bad it's
just going
but when I start thinking too much it's
going like this it's going like that I
need it to go like it's like
um
then I'm almost too attached to it
you know whereas if I can sit back and
just watch life kind of happen
and not overreact to it just recognize
it's always good that's a thing life
hadn't been tricking anybody
life's got two hands bruh
and it'll give you some bird see with
one and
and it'll punch it down it'll punch you
in a [__] neck with daughter
that's life
will hand you a couple little
um butterscotches bruh
with one hand and then while you sucking
on them mitts
hit you with the other hand
that's life
life has always done that
it's that butterscotch freaking bad boy
son
it's a James J Brad utter scotch
that thing will it'll punch you while
you freaking enjoying some sugar
but if I so at a certain point I gotta
know that I gotta know hey look this is
what life does
but if I'm a so attached to it then I'm
gonna do then I'm gonna be riding like
that too
if I put my saddle on every moment
but if I can just kind of sit in the
middle and know
it's going to be high it's going to be
low
mama's gonna ride her bro I'm a rider
then I don't get caught on the waves and
the crevasses
I'm just chumming the boat man yeah it's
gonna be tough here it's gonna be
untoughed here
let's enjoy the sailing huh let's do
some smooth sailing
um better help I want to let you know
that this episode is brought to you by
better help that's right
better help
if you need something if you are missing
ways of connecting your life
if you're not feeling like your old self
you could be evolving
as soon as you need help doing that
sometimes you need a reflective surface
you need somebody to help you see who
you are
and get a real look at yourself that's
right better help they can be there for
you
if you're thinking of starting therapy
give them a try better help it's
entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
at any time for no additional charge
find more balance with better help
visit betterhelp.com
t-h-e-o today to get 10 off your first
month that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash Theo
summer's coming it's coming fast dang it
might have already came on yeah
are you ready to unveil your Beach bod
and I'm not but manscaped is here to
ensure your body is ready for the wild I
just use their Tremor and just trimmed
up my uh chest and belly so made enough
got enough hair to make a dang Mitten
for somebody for a cold hand
or a Hoover make a damn hair condom for
someone it's time to get ready for a hot
guy Summer by going to manscape.com for
20 off and free shipping with the code
Theo that's right manscaped is dedicated
to helping you increase your confidence
and level up your full body grooming
game
with the performance package 4.0 that's
right
no one likes nose hairs they can get
them they got the weed whacker 2.0
they got it all get 20 off in free
shipping
with code Theo at manscaped.com that's
20 off and free shipping with the code
t-h-e-o at manscaped.com
trim your hair do it well do it right
manscaped
not trying to preach at you just trying
to share some things you know um I've
been doing a little more meditation
recently and it's been allowing me to
have a little bit of space
from uh the attachment to every moment
and that has been nice it's been nice
even just a little bit of space has been
nice what's going on with you guys
um I want to thank everybody that's came
out over there in Phoenix I'll be seeing
everybody in New York this week New York
City
um we're trying to put some other shows
on the books we got Edmonton
is out there uh new date sets up now our
new date uh it's gonna be outdoors so no
idea what that's going to be like
no idea
um
but we'll see when we get there that's
what I'm thinking
uh
what's been happening uh what's been
happening with you
I want to get some voicemails from you
guys other dates we're looking at
Australia and the uh UK we're looking to
try to figure those out right now
um
so man I can't even believe it to get to
go back to some of those beautiful
places and
oh
just thank you so much thank you for
um
wanting me to come
you know
uh physically you know
and uh or you know to show up you know
I'm just I'm not talking about
EJ EJ e jacking
I'm talking about just showing up and
doing work
um
what's going on man on boy
happy Mother's Day you know we had a lot
of different we had a lot of different
mothers in my neighborhood
foreign
my God
she would God damn I mean good God
my mom I think she [__] slept on the
top of a violin that [__] was high
strong
she was good damn
my mother had that kind of if my my
mother she was she was tight she was
wound tight
if she turned her neck one of her arms
would go up to beat the [__] out of
somebody
see that's just how she was built just
like one of those old toys you get like
as a kid back in the day they'd have a
toy and if you turn like if you moved
its leg
then then the arm would it was double
it was ambidextrous
so you move you know you moved its neck
one of its arms would go up
and you moved its leg and then the other
arm it would just you couldn't move one
part without another apartment that's
how my mom was
she just had she was wound up
if she sneezed she beat the [__] out of
something she just you know she it was
just my mother was wound up boy they had
all kinds of moms in our neighborhood
we had this one lady she would she drank
boy
she drank and she ate uh
Christmas candies year round
she ate Christmas candies year round his
[__] was eating Christmas Candice
year-round boy year round
and first if that ain't the most sinful
thing seeing somebody
suck on a piece of Christmas candy dude
in this damn June what's going on God
the devil's out here selling sugar
and she was naughty bro she had a Trans
Am I remember she had like a sports car
and she would she drink a lot
she would drink a lot and I remember
she'd lay out on the clock she would lay
on the hood of that car dude she'd dry
she'd go drive it a couple times and
then she'd lay on the hood of it while
it was still warm this right does
three Apartments down from us
she'd lay on that [__]
and she would just kind of just how like
she'd say I want you what would you say
I want
she'd be like yeah
and then she drank a little take a sip
of her drink it was usually a uh
Corona
and she'd say I want you to hear me feel
and she would just yeah
she would howl a little
God boy
and her damn legs would look all wet and
I mean I don't even know what was going
on
God that lady was
she was [__] Wild Boy
and somebody she said that she had
barrettes on her uh
uh on the hair outside of her cooter
foreign
laying on that warm engine
um what else we had another we had some
this my buddy had a thick mom she went
down thick boy God damn dude
she looked like she made out of damn
bread you know
like when you saw her you just wanted to
damn just put some jelly on that [__]
you just want to damn put some jelly on
that batch and enjoy yourself God damn
boy I put that [__] in the oven son
and her their whole house smelled like
biscuits
and they had a mixed child over there
too
and the mama Shelley wore kind of
Hospital clothes even though she wasn't
in in in in the hospital
I guess she was just ready because it
eventually they took her in and she
passed away
she had uh blood pressure or something I
don't know
just them salt in her blood or something
damn biscuit blood or something that
happened to her she was God damn boy
she was beautiful
and then they had another buddy of mine
had a his mom was she was God she was
beautiful
she was beautiful man I'd go over there
and I'd hide in their clothes hamper
I had to hide in there
then I would smell her uh
brass ears that's God I would just
I wanted her to be my mother
I would put my I would get those things
and put them on my just right I would
just
just huffing cups baby I just wanted to
just inhale
the scent of that woman until it landed
in my
DNA man I wanted her to be my mother
that much I remember that
I remember that
um
I can barely see these sunglasses are
damn they want it all to stop son
everything
but let's get a couple of uh calls that
came in here the hotline is always
985-664-9503
um I do want to update you that me and
David Spades are still trying to get a
movie made which would be insane boy
I don't know if that'll happen we're
trying
uh a lot of these Studios and stuff
they're not giving it they don't
there's no
um
we haven't had any luck on the
traditional route
you know I think there's a big they
don't want to see uh
something like that they don't want to
see that kind they don't want two guys
they don't just don't want I don't think
two white guys having a good time
to be real honest with you
and some of that might be a little jaded
but I can't understand why
they wouldn't jump at the opportunity
for for the film I mean I well I mean I
don't have a lot of experience I don't
have any experience let's be honest with
you boy I don't have any experience
hey you got experience I don't I don't
have any and the baby came from the sky
oh God
um
but this is David down Spades bro call
us Spades of Spades baby that's him
that's Tommy Boy's brother dog
so that's Joe damn dirt bro his parents
left him at the Grand Canyon and now
he's a movie star
so that [__] just makes me wanna [__]
juggle my own dick buddy
so I don't know we're trying to find an
alternative method to get it made
I might hit up a rich friend or
something and see if they'll put some
financing I I don't know but I just
wanted to update you on that
um
what else I watch at UFC this weekend I
enjoyed it
I was I was bummed that Bryce Mitchell
didn't fight
but you know you got to take care of
yourself that's important
and uh
anyway as always the hotline
985-664-9503
thank you
it's up for you Gage from Pittsburgh
what's up Gage in uh Pittsburgh as well
I like it I've been there got pink eye
over there
you know what I'm saying got a little
bit of downtime in my uptime you feel me
onward brother
I'm having my third kid in August I got
two girls already I'm hoping for a boy
doing a gender reveal party
I want to know how would Theo Vaughn do
it
gang gang baby
praise brother I appreciate you asking
me and congratulations on that third
buddy congratulations on that bringing
something into the world an idea
a human idea
um
I think this is how I would do it
I'd get you these mommies and daddy out
there get you mommy and daddy right your
parents or her parents
I get you a four-wheeler okay
and not run you a uh I'd run you a thing
of rope
from the back of the four-wheeler to
each one of the parents
to their pants to the front of their
pants
and they're wearing pants only each
parent pants only no wonders
no wonders
and then you tie it whichever it is male
or female if it's male the new baby you
tie it you tie the knot tight onto the
front of your your dad's pants
and if it's female you tie it tight onto
the front of your mom's pants
and whichever one it isn't you leave it
loose but you still make it look like
it's up by their waist right you tuck it
into their waist or whatever so nobody
would know the difference
and then
you say okay one two three male or
female or whatever they do you know let
me see you know move that
whatever gender whatever they say right
and
uh let's see the winner whatever you
know or whatever this I don't know how
you guys do it right and that's a crotch
okay who is it the baby is the Beauty
World
so here's what I'm saying man is that
then you explore that four-wheeler and
whoever it is if it's male or female it
rips the pants off of the adult
now that's some [__] [__] right there
boy
that's a so then you're really revealing
somebody's gender
you're revealing two genders you're
saying hey the baby's gonna be this and
we're also making sure that your parents
are appropriately crossed by God
because imagine well you ripped him uh
pantalones off mom
and she got that hog on her boy
she got the that little worker boy
she got that little semen snout on her
boy everybody'd be damn shocked that's a
double gender reveal
then she's gonna have a new
granddaughter and you're gonna have a
new
father
so that's how I would do it man but what
do I know
nothing
all right let's take another call right
here hey Theo my name is Riley I just
got a simple question what do you think
of my car it's a 2012 Suzuki SX4
hatchback uh that's all I wanted to know
gang gang gang baby thank you Riley for
calling in on that Auto
and um
I don't know fiscally I don't know much
about it you know you need to look up in
Kelley Blue Book
or get you on the website or something
admins or something I don't know
you know we used to have that Kelly Blue
Book and we look on there
and see oh wow my car is a piece of [__]
I remember realizing wasn't even in
there
the value of this damn wasn't even in
there God
but um I love that it's a Kia Sorrento
huh is that what you said
what do you think of my car it's a 2012
Suzuki SX4 hatchback okay that's all I
wanted to know Suzuki gang gang
yeah we used to have a brother by us
that grew up by us
and they called them Suzuki leg
and uh
I don't know why I don't know what
happened or what it something happened
to his leg I think he'd
um
well I know what happened his brother it
burned down uh their garage his brother
had locked him in a garage or something
burned it down
and part of his leg got grilled out a
little and for some reason they uh
they call him Suzuki leg over there
I don't know I don't know why
I'll have to go back and ask somebody
but I remember that but yeah look that's
a beautiful car you said 2012 2012 was a
great year man
that was when
uh the Russians
uh ended that they had a beef and issue
with
the UK remember they wouldn't let the
beef in from the UK
and that's when the Russians they in
they ended that uh is that an embargo
what is an embargo let me see
an embargo an official band or trade on
trade yep the Russians that's 2012 they
ended that embargo that beef embargo
that they had that meat embargo going on
they didn't want that beef coming in
from uh Britain
they didn't want that Bread is made
and so they ended it but at that point
it was unlimited Russian beef was
allowed in in uh you know unlimited
British beef was allowed in Russia and
people were damn [__] throwing loins
at each other just you'd see a man just
beating his wife with a damn London
broil
over there in Russia
you know just God just
you know just whipping it just you'd see
somebody whipping their child with a
damn back strap
you know it was damn beautiful
um
but that's yeah because I used to work
in meat I used to do door-to-door meat
work uh
I used to do door-to-door meat work we
would do
you know where you'd knock on people's
door and sell them to me right there
and people want to be people look people
there's something about me
people want it
people want it people want meat baby
they want it
and if you show up at somebody's house
and you're like guess what and they're
like what you're like I got some [__]
meat right here some a decent amount of
people want it
now some vegans will call you a queer or
whatever
you know
but that's them
um
anyway sorry I'm rambling man let's get
back into it uh but yeah I used to do
door-to-door meat it was truck to table
right there and we would sell it to
people right there uh
you know it was that you know
it was freezer to table I don't know
what it was but it was we'd sell that
[__] right out the truck
in different neighborhoods you hit you
know you'd knock and tell them you had
different stuff ribs bruh if you was in
some of the urban neighborhood you'd be
like hey guess what
we ribbon around over here you know
I'm driving that rib Rover you feel me
we ribbed up who want these ribs so
praise God happy Mother's Day
you know the sun is it's God it's it's
violent look at what the sun can do burn
a hole in a uh Leaf if you have a
magnifying glass kill an ant
that's why our friends at Shady Rays
have you covered for the warm weather
ahead with premium polarized Shades at
an afaratable affordable sorry price
Shady raises in independent sunglasses
company that offers a world-class
product that's just as good as any
expensive pair
we've ever worn that's true
that's not all shady Rays offers the
most insane protection in all of eyewear
every pair of sunglasses is backed by
lost and broken Replacements yep if you
lose or break your pair even on day one
they told us they will send you a brand
new pair no questions asked
if you don't love your shady Rays
exchanger for a new payer return them
within 30 days as well exclusively for
our listeners Shady Rays is giving out
the best deal of the Season go to
shadyraise.com and use code t-h-e-o for
50 off two plus pairs of polarized
sunglasses
try for yourself the shades rated 5
Stars by over a quarter million people
shadyraise.com use code Theo you know I
was in a car accident
um probably four years ago
some lady did a u-turn and she didn't
know how to do it and she just
she you turned right into me it was more
of a j and I was at the end of the J
and I got just jacked up that's what
happened
if you're ever injured
in a car accident or injured at all and
it's some type of accident you can check
out Morgan and Morgan
and Morgan is America's largest injury
Law Firm they have over 100 offices
Nationwide and more than 800 lawyers
with over 15 billion dollars were
covered for clients Morgan and Morgan
has a proven track record of fighting
till you get your full and fair
compensation
submitting an injury claim with Morgan
and Morgan is so easy it's more like
using an app than hiring a lawyer
with Morgan Morgan you can submit a
claim without ever having to leave the
couch and you might not be able to heck
if you're hurt if you're ever injured
you can check out Morgan and Morgan
their fee is free unless they win
for more information go to
forthepeople.com
this past weekend
or dial pound law that's pound 529 from
your cell phone that's for the
people.com
this past weekend or pound 529 from your
cell phone this is a paid advertisement
all right let's take another call here
here we go
hey Steve man
um I just wanted to call and say man
it's been rough I've had a pretty rough
couple years and
um I've been watching you for a long
time and you're you're just hilarious
man and I just find you so funny and I
was watching some clips on on YouTube
and one of them was you just saying that
you're proud of me and that was the
first time I've heard that in a long
time so I just wanted to say thank you
and I just wanted to know kind of what
you do for support how do you get
support how do you make yourself feel
better I just want to know thank you oh
thanks for the uh for the message
brother
um
yeah you know you might be like me you
might be somebody that didn't hear that
when they needed to when they were young
you know and that's not self-pity I'm
not like oh boo hoo but the long-term
effects of those things are very real
they're very real man
they're very real and um
and I'm sorry you're having to deal with
these things later in life
but you're not the only person
you know it's a lot of us that are
dealing with this we kind of late
bloomers you know
um
and it makes me angry that I have to
deal with I have to deal I have to
meander around these things now which
are things that should have been done
for me as a child it makes me angry
right
but I have to take some action and
that's what we do we go to we do therapy
we do different processes
um you can uh do 12-step you can do
Ayahuasca there's different things you
can do to help you uh fill in that space
and learn
um and relearn the things you should
have learned as a child or should have
known and felt as a child
uh me for support
you know this podcast really in some
ways has been has been the one thing
that's made me show up for my life every
week
you know if there's one thing I've done
in my life that I've committed to and
I've done it
it's this
honestly
so this has been a great thing my
brother has been really great for me
my brother has been really
man
you know I don't know where I would be
without my brother man
I mean he had a really tough time when
we were kids he had a really tough time
and uh
you know he uh
and you know
um
and I was the younger brother you know
so I came in this need and you know
you know and probably what little he was
getting
that he needed as a child I came in and
cut that in half
you know uh
but he is just a really interesting and
resilient and
um
and powerful force in my life I go to
him a lot we've had a our relationship
has built as I've gotten older and as
he's got as we've grown up and
it has been a blessing man
you know my brother's the first person
in my life that I ever felt like love me
just unconditionally unconditionally
he chose to he just
you know he chose uh that
for me I had an ex-girlfriend that loved
me unconditionally too actually
um I wasn't ready to be
uh
but good you know a decent husband or or
decent boyfriend but
um but my brother I go to my brother
who else do I go to
he really is the one that um
you know he kind of he's my you know in
some ways he turned into my father too
you know he had to fill in a lot of
roles that we didn't have
um
and he did it for himself first and then
he's been able to extend and help me uh
when I've needed it so
so that has been a just really man
that's been a blessing thank you for
asking
all right we got another video call that
came in here some of these are video
and for all of these you can go to
theovan.com and you can um there's three
ways to communicate with the podcast you
can text
um
those are where we just kind of uh
respond to sometimes
um you can send audio and video and uh
we listen and watch those
um and some of those we'll use for
episodes uh thank you
hi Theo my name is Ashley and
that
is my beautiful Kane Corso named Abraham
okay and hello Ashley thank you for uh
checking in here nice to see you and you
got that animal too you got that uh
you got that dark that uh that dark
animal in the back seat onward my
question is about uh whether or not Theo
has any words of encouragement or just
thoughts about having to re-home a pet
um I'll actually be moving from South
Carolina to Covington Louisiana
in June so uh I have to re-home her I
can't take her with me just Logistics
wise so I wanted to know what your
thoughts were about that
well thank you yeah look I I think if
you're gonna bring an animal down to
Louisiana we'll we that's good
it's an animal place man
name 70 animals
I bet you a lot of them are right there
in Louisiana if you do
um
yeah I mean I grew up in the Stray
animal belt over there and so I don't
know a ton about dogs I believe in them
I've seen them my whole life you know um
the area I grew up in a lot of stray
animals I mean we had stress everything
was stray
I mean from the damn Birds to
uh this hell this one family down the
street
you catch the damn that daughter
drinking not the ditch uh
but we had a lot of stray animals come
through
you know and so I don't have
the first time I ever saw a dog in a
home it was it blew my mind
it was a beautiful blonde-haired
blue a brown eyed animal oh my God damn
that thing's fine as hell boy
my thing's fine as hell nothing [__]
grill that thing up over at the Asian
Church you feel me oh don't you love us
Lord we love you
[Music]
what was I talking about
yeah so I don't have much experience on
rehoming animals but
but it's obvious you care about the
animal you're gonna find it a good home
and I think just welcome to Covington
Louisiana
you know it's a great place it's a warm
place
um there's a lot of good people
uh it's a good place to raise a child
it's a good place to be a mom
um there's a strong sense of community
over there and uh I'm sure you will like
it it's a great place to have an
imagination
and I'm thankful to that place uh for
just giving me a tapestry to be on
as a
as I pass through time here yeah I don't
know we had a stray animal I mean I got
bit by you know I mean damn I got bit by
so many [__] dogs God
them [__] would [__] bite me I
thought there was something in me I
thought I had a damn pork loin in me or
something
you know
I thought you know God was hiding bacon
in my ass or something them dogs would
[__] latch on to me
so anyway good luck to you and
congratulations on the move
all right let's take one more call and
um
yeah let's see what we got as always the
hotline is 985-664-9503
[Music]
um
here we go
my name is Danielle
I live on the west side of Michigan
um Great Lakes great times that murder
Mitten yeah baby that murder Mitten
that's it if you want to get murdered
and you want to hear Kid Rock blasting
in the background while you do it you
got to go to Michigan buddy
and enjoy yourself onward no
um but anyways I just got pulled in a
little early uh to this you know program
that I'm participating in and I just
wanted to touch base I was listening to
you you know on my Drive-In this morning
and recently you've just been talking a
lot about like taking time for yourself
like you know prioritizing like life
moves real quickly and um
you know that that's that's true
and uh I've recently made the decision
to
um you know take some time off for
myself and and get some therapy and some
medication to kind of battle the dark
arts in my heart and my soul in my mind
uh
you know
um
we're out here man we're doing it and
you know I'm a career person I'm a mom
I'm a wife you know I got a lot of
responsibility but you know at the end
of the day I had to make the decision to
uh
help myself you know uh because what's
the cost if you don't right so
amen
Danielle thank you for the call and
happy Mother's Day to you
um
and yeah I'm uh
you know mothers are the real
they're the real worst they they're the
you know mother they get it all
they get they're there you know it's a
lot of
they're the toll booth
they're the on-ramp
there's a it's a lot of responsibility
you're running around with a damn portal
between the heavens and existence and
the world
yeah
this I'm sure it is stressful
dear God I can't even make it through a
damn toll booth if I don't know the
change right I [__] lose my [__]
so to be carrying a you know a portal
to be in everything that is scary you're
like that you're the Greyhound station
of the Lord
and you know how much things get left at
a greyhound
all kind of this and that and old jacket
somebody left a damn uh
uh
oven mid over there and half of milk
dude I saw a sister drinking a can of
damn Similac one time
calling somebody a homo on the phone
once at Philadelphia over there by the
bust by the Greyhound so it's all kind
of [__]
you know and when being a mom being all
that
there's a lot coming at you you're a
you're the
you're the nucleus really of the family
really in a lot of ways a lot passing
through you
and there's a lot that's been going on
in history you know I think so many
things happened over the past centuries
Wars and battles
and love and loss
and only now in the present Society
really are we really at a place where
we've come up kind of for air
where all of our needs are kind of met
where we can
look at our emotions see what's going on
how we feel what's happening
and
it makes perfect sense to take time and
clean your mirror
so I'm proud of you
yeah look even NASCAR they put them they
do nine laps and pulling [__] in the
shop
and those are the most greatest cars on
earth
so it makes sense that we take time and
take care of ourselves it makes sense
that we find ways to be happy and take
care of ourselves so I'm proud of you I
don't think there's anything uh
yeah look this is your time it's mother
this Mother's we it's your time
so yeah you take care of yourself take
all the time that you need
um
yeah it's important we have to take care
what yeah if you don't have yourself
what do you have
sometimes I find I'm I'm hurrying for
what
I've always felt like that in my life of
God I heard get this done so I can but
there's not a thing
there's never a thing that I'm hurt it's
an invis it's like somebody's fired a
gun at a starting line a long time ago
and I've just been going
so take time
take care of yourself play girl we doing
good what else not much dude shave my
chest the other day feeling okay about
that a little nervous about it
uh
uh you know my tits don't look exactly
like I would like but that's God that's
what he's doing
you know one of my tits looks like a
little bit of like a melt like somebody
put a scoop of ice cream but it's just
starting to melt a little
so
but hey
who don't love a little bit of sweet
cream can I have some
um I want to thank you guys
I want to thank you mothers for being
mothers
um we're gonna go out this kind of a sad
song
but I'm used to listen to this song A
lot when I needed to process feelings of
uh
of connection that I didn't have with my
own mother
I would listen to this not all the time
but I would listen when I really was in
a moment was like okay I need to Pro you
know when I could feel some of those
feelings come on I would listen to this
song because it would help me process
them
and it would help me get those out of my
uh system you know
um
so let's listen to that now this is Evan
bartel's the devil God and me uh Happy
Mother's Day to all of the mothers out
there
um we love you
and uh and thank you for what you do
and um
thank you
be good to yourselves you know that baby
game
[Music]
now this is an emo one
so if you don't like that emote and go
on on about yourself nobody's keeping
you here
gang baby
Evan Bartels man
[Music]
love y'all baby
this is a great big world waiting right
outside
[Music]
my mother
Mary is my voice
[Music]
we the people have that choice
though I did not try my best
mother may I slipped away